Gary Halbert is one of the highest paid
copywriters ever to live and he used to
teach this lesson to college students
about how to get the most amount of
sales with the least amount of leverage.
And here's what he told them. He said,
"I'm going to give you an example. You
guys have to open a burger shop on the
corner and I'm going to open up a burger
shop on the corner, too. And you guys
get to pick one unique aspect that your
burger shop has an advantage over every
other burger shop in the city, okay? You
guys do that and then I'm going to do it
and I guarantee the one unique advantage
that I pick is going to blow all of your
burger shops out of the water. Now,
after he did this exercise with all
those college students, he would have
them raise their hands. Okay, what's
your unique advantage? Everybody tell me
what your unique advantage. And they
would raise their hands. They'd be like,
"We have superior ingredients." Okay,
good burgers. Nice one, nice one. What
about you in the corner? "Uh we have the
best location. The most foot traffic
walks by." Okay, fantastic. Okay, what
else? What else? What about you in the
corner? "We have the cheapest prices."
Okay, we're the most competitive. Okay,
interesting, interesting. And then they
all look at him and he says, "I blow all
of you out of the water. My unique
advantage absolutely dominates all of
you." And they look at him dumbfounded.
They're like, "What is this guy talking
about? How is he going to blow all of us
out of the water?" And he says, "I have
the one unique advantage that beats all
that." And they're sitting here
wondering, "What is it?" He says, "My
one unique advantage is a starving
crowd, okay? And that is the greatest
marketing lesson you could ever have in
your copy, in your sales, in anything.
The number one advantage that you want
is a starving crowd. People who are
already hungry for what you sell. This
is the opposite of what most people do.
Most people try and think of a product
that they like and want to sell instead
of a problem that they want to serve.
You have to find a huge problem that
people are hungry to buy the solve for
and sell them that. Do that and I
guarantee it will explode your business.